[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a escala en París una
emisión de radio Francia internacional
en colaboración con la televisión fans
24 en español en la que cada semana
damos la palabra a personas del mundo de
las ciencias las artes la cultura la
política los deportes y claro está de la
sociedad civil Cuba ha sido una de
músicos escritores poetas y ritmos
musicales que han dado la vuelta al
mundo Hay que ser un poco osado
aventurero para lanzarse el desafío de
contar en un solo tomo en un solo libro
La historia de esa isla pero hay que ser
muy bueno para lograrlo es el caso de
Marcel quille veré autor del libro Cuba
una historia de la isla por su música y
su cultura a quien recibimos hoy en esta
escala en París Marcel muy feliz por
tenerlo con nosotros en esta escala
Muchas gracias Un verdadero placer
Muchas gracias
por ese gran trabajo que ustedes que
usted ha realizado su primer viaje a
Cuba fue en 1975 volvió
varias ocasiones allá de donde surgió la
idea de hacer ese maravilloso libro
Es que
yo fui profesor de español Para ganarme
la vida
vengo de un medio bastante humilde en
Bretaña y habé español en Bretaña a los
14 años a los 16 lo hablaba
perfectamente y decidí ganarme la vida a
los 19 años siendo profesor y cuando
enseñé el español a mis amigos yo tenía
Esa visión de Cuba Bueno de la
Revolución que era para mí una
Revolución
humanitaria
humanista
libre feliz y fui a Cuba con una mochila
en aquella época no necesitábamos visa
pero cuando llegué claro se dieron
cuenta de que yo era un tipo un poco
extraño y la seguridad del estado se
hizo cargo de mí me metieron en un hotel
que no podía vagar porque no tenía
dinero y ahí fue un amigo que un amigo
de la UNESCO me dijo que podía llamar
por si acaso tenía problemas y me hizo
conocer a una señora maravillosa Rosa
Torres una señora negra de pampanante
del carnaval Y viví con ella pues como
verán ustedes la historia de Marcel que
lleve Está también hace parte también de
la historia de Cuba el libro que usted
ha realizado Inicia por Santiago es ahí
donde por razones históricas
efectivamente se puede decir empieza
también la música cubana y donde hay
gran influencia de la parte de los
africanos
en ritmos y sobre todo de la mezcla con
ritmos nativos
la música clásica que es importante
también
totalmente
comenzó ahí en Santiago con Esteban
salas allí comenzó el sol en la sierra
son de la Loma cantan en Llano cantan en
Llano efectivamente Marcel A menos del
siglo 19 La Isla se afirma ya como
dijéramos una nación que quiere
independizarse del yugo español antes de
lograr su independencia y a mí lo que me
llamó la atención es que descubrí a
través del libro Cuba la historia de La
Isla al paganini mulato José White
qué señor qué señor José White fue el
primer gran violinista cubano
de un papá francés porque hay influencia
de España de españoles hay influencia de
franceses hay influencia de africanos
está la gente nativa o sea es una mezcla
impresionante es impresionante la vida
de José guaitas un poco la vida de Cuba
No él viajó mucho acabó aquí en París
fue profesor en el conservatorio de
París murió aquí en 1918 y aquí compuso
esa famosa melodía que canta cada cubano
hoy en día que se llama la bella cubana
José White fue profesor el compositor
rumano y de nuestro gran violinista
reactivo porque Déjenme decirles que la
historia de Cuba a través de la música y
su literatura también es un libro lleno
de fotografías una cantidad
impresionante de archivos fotográficos
que recorren precisamente la historia de
esa gran Isla Marcel antes de y después
de la Independencia de Cuba usted lo
señalaba ya hay gente muy famosa músicos
muy famosos que pasaron por ahí uno de
ellos es albenis pero otra cosa que fue
en 1875 cuando visita La Isla antes de
regresar después y otro personaje que me
apasionó por cuestión de preferencia
personal es que en 1920 el más grande
tenor de todos los tiempos y dije que
Enrique caruso estuvo en la isla
interpretando precisamente a ida pero se
presentó una situación un poco jocosa
usted recuerda esa situación hubo un
ruido enorme durante la función que era
como la gente dijo con es una bomba es
una bomba y el pobre caruso en el
escenario huyó salió de escenario pero
estaba vestido de de radamés de egipcio
Y claro la policía se dieron Bueno es un
loco que se escapó de un asilo de para
Locos de un manicomio y
menos mal estaba el empresario y todo se
arregló por supuesto pero fue la llegada
de carrozo fue un acontecimiento
increíble la gente se lanzó al para
conseguir boletos Ya no había era
increíble era increíble Claro porque era
un corazón que atraía corazón como
ciudad la Habana pero no solo la Habana
porque caruso está en 1920 titoshipa
otro gran tenor llega en 1921 pero fuera
de eso y esta anécdota de caruso se
produjo en el famoso teatro tacón
cuatro mil localidades más grande
exactamente exactamente
en Cuba antes de los Estados Unidos en
1818 antes de New York es increíble no
sin razón decimos que Cuba Precisamente
es cuna de músicos de ritmos de poetas
de escritores Marcel hablemos ahora de
algunos de los ritmos que nacieron en
Cuba y que decíamos en un principio han
recorrido el mundo entero estamos
hablando del son estamos hablando de la
guajira de la Trova entre otras cosas y
del danzón
[Música]
todo nace es una historia bellísima todo
nace con la contradanza
que es una mala traducción de country
Dance
Lance de primus en Inglaterra que llegó
a Francia y que tradujeron mal no baile
de campo no no no se tradujo contra
danza de allí pasó España de España de
Cádiz llegaron a Cuba y sobre todo
cuando la rebelión de tusanudez en Haití
gran Independencia casi todos Hasta
Santiago y ahí la contradanza empezó
mezclándose con los ritmos de Santiago
de Cuba la ciudad afrocubana por
excelencia llegó a la Habana con esa
cosa que empezó a cambiar
hombre exactamente el ritmo que estamos
escuchando
exactamente y hay que recordar
simplemente que en el caso de la Trova
nace con una enorme canción que es
considerada el segundo himno de Cuba la
bayamesa la bella mesa
cuidado hay dos vaya mesa vamos a
diferir no la primera vaya mesa es de
Manuel de Céspedes que fue el gran
independiente Claro pero después la otra
designogaray es otra cosa ciertamente no
tiene nada que ver con la primera
bueno independientemente de esto porque
el tiempo Corre muy rápidamente Marcel
hay otra cosa que es el primer Danzón
fue a las alturas del Simpson sí que
viene de la ciudad Sí exactamente era de
la ciudad de matanzas ciertamente usted
lo decía hay muchos músicos hay muchos
artistas hay muchos escritores que
pasaron por Cuba un ocaso un caso de
célebre uno de los grandes personajes es
Federico García Lorca
el viaje de Lorca Yo creo para él fue el
momento más feliz de su vida estar en
Cuba y yo tuve la el honor de conocer
a su Cómo se llama su nieta
Laura García Lorca que dirige hoy la
fundación Lorca yo viaje ahí nos hablaba
mucho ella conoció en Nueva York conoció
un gran compositor cubano Juliana Mormón
hablamos de Cuba y ella me entregó esas
fotos del libro que son maravillosas la
llegada de Lorca yo no sé yo creo que
Cuba fue fue la capital de su felicidad
allí vivió feliz
y sobre todo pudo expresar más
fácilmente su homosexualidad porque la
vida en Cuba era mucho más abierta que
en España Imagínate tú ciertamente
hay mucho que contar evidentemente por
ejemplo el papel de las mujeres usted
menciona en el libro importantísimo
háblenos de ese precisamente el papel
que jugaron sobre todo en la creación de
probarte musical pero el arte musical
fue fundada por mujeres pero si me
permite usted señor Ya en 1902 la
medicina en Cuba Era la más famosa de
todas las américas y había mujeres allí
muchas mujeres y eran investigadoras
científicas increíble y llega los años
20 con esas mujeres de proarte que
llegan
pueden como recogen el dinero para
construir un teatro que era uno de los
más bellos de latinoamérica el teatro
auditorio que hoy se llama Roldán pero
que está en un estado lamentable de
ruinas hoy en Cuba allí pasaron los más
grandes de la lírica internacional
Lamentablemente el tiempo se va volando
en una misión como escala en París damos
un salto en el tiempo larguísimo de
manera muy breve Cómo evalúa usted hoy
la evolución de la música y de las artes
en Cuba Hoy después del 2017 cuando ha
habido el levantamiento más importante
2021 Perdón más importante las protestas
más importantes de la población bueno de
una manera muy breve bueno el único
amigo que me queda ahí en Cuba es un
músico es un gran compositor es el
sobrino de Virgilio Piñera el dermaturgo
cubano más importante es Juan Piñera y
hablé con él al teléfono
hace tres días y me contó lo que pasaba
el pobre ya no tiene alumnos hubo una
huida de casi 350
300.000 o 400.000 jóvenes y todos los
músicos que yo conocí por él jóvenes que
tenían 15 años todos se fueron es el
único profesor de hoy en día y me dijo
que la Facultad de artes y ya no tiene
profesores los que todos huyeron y que a
lo mejor se van a cerrar la Facultad de
artes de lisa y yo no sé lo que va a
pasar pero es muy grave la situación es
muy grave Se desconoce y y por ejemplo
Ah me contó lo del festival de cine que
cuando aparecieron los aparecieron los
oficiales y el director del festival el
público entero abucheo
que es un gran acontecimiento en Cuba
usted sabe Claro pues esperemos que esta
situación Por lo menos se mejore
inmediato está sufriendo mucho y sobre
todo pueda seguir fertilizando
fructificando esa maravillosa música ese
maravilloso hay músicos todavía y muy
muy importantes Porque esa sociedad
civil sigue luchando y expresándose por
la música Marcel Sandoval tiempo yo le
Quiero agradecer su presencia recuerdo
el libro Cuba la historia de La Isla su
música y su literatura lo que puede ser
un regalo maravilloso en este fin de año
muy amables por haber venido y
acompañado Gracias
de
federicona los dejamos aquí yo me
despido Braulio Moro Hasta muy pronto en
otra escala en París
[Música]